MARZIA NICCOLAI: Hi, welcome
to Optimizing
your App Engine App.
I'm Marzia Niccolai.
GREG DARKE: I'm Greg Darke.
TROY TRIMBLE: And I'm
Troy Trimble.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: And
we're going to be
talking to you today.
Here's a little overview
of the agenda
that we'll be covering.
First, we're going to go into
some coding tips on how to
write your App Engine app
more efficiently.
Then we're going to cover some
performance settings.
And then we're also going to
talk a little bit about what
we're planning in the future and
how this will impact the
way you scale and
write your app.
First, I just want to talk a
little bit about latency
versus cost, which is really
what we're trying to cover
here when we mean optimizing.
Now, these aren't always
conflicting goals.
Sometimes these things are
conflicting and sometimes when
you optimize for one, you
optimize for the other.
My general rule of thumb when
I think about these things
are, if I make something more
efficient, that's generally
also going to lower its cost.
If I'm using more resources to
accomplish lower latency,
that's usually going to be
higher costs for me.
And sometimes with App Engine
and the way we have our
performance settings available,
you can choose to
lower the amount of resources
you're using.
It's going to be less cost,
but it's also going to be
slightly slower latency.
Now, the other question
is, what do we
mean by good latency?
So I've put up a slide here from
an admin console graph on
an application that I work on,
and I've highlighted your
lowest latency handler and our
highest latency handler.
Now, for the base handler, 46
milliseconds, I'm just going
to say I think that's
pretty good.
It's what your user's going to
hit the first time they come
to your app.
46 milliseconds, they get
something served to them.
Now.
The highest latency handler,
you're going to ask 942
milliseconds, basically,
1 second.
Is that good or that bad?
Well, I mean, a lot
of that depends.
And a lot of that really covers
the heart of what we're
talking about today,
which is, well,
who's seeing that request?
If your user's seeing that
request, is a second good?
But if it's just some requests
running in the backend, maybe
I don't care if it's
942 milliseconds.
Of course, in this case,
it's something that's
asynchronously requested
but served to my user.
So I see that 942
milliseconds.
I'm saying, well,
it's not bad.
But could I be doing
something better?
I probably could.
Apparently, I have to be
standing here to get
the thing to work.
OK, so I just want to say that
we're using Python here for
our code examples.
But really, a lot of these
things are language agnostic.
When we do say something that's
language specific,
we'll call it out.
And even the Python, please
don't copy and paste this
Python in your app because it's
more as an example of
good and bad things to do, not
really production-ready code.
So the first thing, what I'm
going to talk about, is
Datastore tips.
And I'm going to structure this,
first, things that we've
actually seen, things
not to do.
And then some general tips
of things to do.
Now, the first thing I get
asked are, what are some
general strategies when I'm
actually writing my models for
the Datastore?
And what I always try to tell
people is think about the
pages that you're serving to
the users and try to design
your models so that those pages
are served efficiently.
And, of course, pages that you
rarely see, you shouldn't
spend as much time optimizing
as pages that you see a lot.
Because those are going to be
the bulk of your requests and
the bulk of your costs.
And this isn't really related to
optimizing your app per se,
but everyone wanted
me to plug.
Make sure you put your app
on the higher application
Datastore or migrate your app
because now you can't really
create apps on the Master/Slave
Datastore.
But this is going to be the most
important of all because
you want your app to be reliable
above everything
else, and the HRD Datastore
will help you do that.
So I have some specific examples
of things I'm going
to go over.
And I'll just dive
right into those.
This is my first Datastore
anti-pattern.
It generally looks something
like this.
You have a query and you're
fetching one result.
And basically, what this code's
supposed to say is I
know what model I want to
retrieve to the Datastore.
So I have to ask myself, why
am I going to query for it?
Instead, we have something
called a Datastore get.
And here I have a get by key
name, which is something I can
set when I create the model.
There's also Datastore IDs if
you don't set a key name.
If you know what the model
you're expecting is, you
really want to try to write
your app so you can use as
many gets as possible.
And the next slide really
shows the reason.
If you look at what happened
when I did a query, well, I
did two Datastore read ops, and
it took me 59 milliseconds
because I had to scan through
some indexes.
After, 1 Datastore fetch
op and 4 milliseconds.
This is really a no-brainer, 50%
less and 14 times faster.
So this is what I mean, cost
and efficiency not always
contradictory.
Of course, for Python, really
this is something that's
language-specific.
Don't use fetch at all.
Fetch actually calls another
function called run and then
puts it in a list.
So you can just cut
out run directly,
which returns a generator.
And that's going to be less
memory for your application.
And anecdotally,
no guarantees.
It's about 10% to 15% faster
because it uses an
asynchronous prefetch, which is
something that Greg's going
to cover a little bit later,
asynchronicity.
But this is something to call
out specifically for Python.
Now, my next Datastore
anti-design pattern is
something that you may not be
using in your app today
because it's something
we just--
I think it was two or three
releases ago, something called
projection queries.
Projection queries are really
good if you're reading data
only and it's a small entity.
This first thing is what an old
query would look like on
App Engine, a model where and
then the filter thing.
Now, the second one looks very
familiar to those of us who
love SQL, which is I'm actually
just selecting the
fields I actually
want to read.
This again, was something not
supported until recently.
But now that it is, if
you just want the
newest update of Firefox--
I think we can wait.
Let's go back to full screen.
So I just want to print out
these two fields from my
model, so that's all I'm going
to retrieve, text and author.
And the big news here is the
first one is a full Datastore
read op, which is $0.07 for
every 100,000 ops in App
Engine pricing.
The second query, $0.01 per
100,000 ops, 85% less.
And this is something that's
really easy to switch out.
But again, one thing to know
about projection queries is
you can't write to an entity
return from a projection
queries, so something
to be aware of.
You can always, if you find
something you want to write,
fetch that entity
and write it.
Or you don't have to replace
it everywhere.
But where you can use it,
you really should.
OK, one of my favorite/least
favorite anti-design patterns,
something that looks really
natural to all of us--
limit offset.
And it seems like a good idea.
Except what happens in App
Engine when you specify an
offset is it scans through those
first 10 indexes and
then reads the next 10.
So basically, you're almost
doing 20 results worth of work
with this query.
What we haven't set in App
Engine is a Datastore cursor.
What cursors do is they return
the place where that query
left off to you.
So the next time you go to run
that query, you can specify
that cursor so it knows
where to start from.
And again, this is something
where you see here 25 fetch
ops in the first example because
we're doing almost all
of the work of the query.
And after, we're just doing the
10 that we want, and it's
47% less, 13 times faster.
So now we're going to get into
some things that you can
really do that will help
improve the efficiency.
And you remember one thing
that I talked about was
minimizing the amount
of work you're doing
when serving a page.
So we've recently introduced
something that's called
embedded entities, and it's a
way to store structured data
within a model.
And what this really can help
you do is denormalize your
data in the sensible way.
So in this case, what you see
is a contact where I want to
store addresses within
a contact.
So I may want to store these
addresses elsewhere or use
them somewhere else.
But I can also store this
model in my contact.
And if I need to put all that
on one page, all the
information is there.
One query, it's really great.
Now, this isn't something that's
going to save you any
money, but it is something
that's going to help your app
run faster.
And the last thing I want to
point out is don't index
things that don't need
to be indexed.
When App Engine serves results,
it always serves them
for a precomputed index
for a query.
So usually, what we do for
most product models on a
property is we write all of
the indexes every time you
create or update that.
But you know that there's some
things that you're not
actually ever going to
want to query on.
In this case, I have something
called a display name.
That's just something that
probably was supposed to look
nice on the page that I want
to store in my model.
I'm never really going to query
on this, so why am I
going to write an index
row every time
I update this model?
So by simply putting index=false
here, when I
update this, that index
row won't get written.
Now, I won't be able
to query on it.
But in this case,
I don't care.
And I've also saved myself some
money because I'm not
writing an index.
Of course, now that we've
covered some Datastore stuff,
we can do better.
Because the data store's still
a lot of work, and so you can
actually add a layer of caching
on top of the Datastore.
It's caching, caching, caching
because there's actually three
different kinds of caching
we're going to cover.
The first one is something
we always are
talking a lot about.
It's Memcache.
Memcache is a fast memory cache
that we have available.
It's basically something where
you can place something that
you frequently--
that is hard to compute, but
you're frequently reading,
either from the Datastore,
or URLFetch, or anything.
But we use the Datastore here.
So in this case, I took the
guest book example, where
you're reading greetings and
we're serving the greetings
every time you hit
the guest book.
So there's no need to pull all
those greetings from the
Datastore every time, even if
it hasn't been updated.
So what I can do instead is
simply add all of that data to
Memcache and pull it when
I look for that page.
And if it's not there,
I can always
read from the Datastore.
Memcache doesn't take
that long of a time.
I do want to point out one thing
that I've done in this
example, which is instead of
actually storing the models in
Memcache, I've stored
some rendered HTML.
And the reason I do this is a
gotcha that we see sometimes,
which is Memcache pickles your
data or serializes your data.
So what happens is, if your
model has changed between
writing and reading
from Memcache, you
might get in trouble.
This is one way to get around
it, or it's just something you
can be aware about when you
update models on your live
serving application.
The next thing I'm going to
cover is instance caching.
Well, what's instance caching?
This is basically the memory of
your App Engine instance,
and it's storing something
in that memory when
the instance is alive.
It allows you to have your
own eviction policy.
Something I didn't mention was
Memcache was the least
recently used evicted.
In this case, storing something
as a global
variable, it allows you to store
it the way you want it.
It is also faster
than Memcache.
It's, well, near
instantaneous.
Memcache is pretty fast, but
there may be some times when
you want it to be faster.
And in this case, you can just
store it as a global variable
in your instance.
But for those Python users,
really what you need to be
doing is using NDB instead.
I've used usually DB examples
in most of my code samples
because NDB is relatively
used.
But I've actually written here
what a real Memcache storing
and reading algorithm
would look like.
I'm not even going to bother to
go through it because it's
got like locks and tombstones
and all of this crazy stuff.
But it's actually hard
to get this right.
Storing things in Memcache,
storing things in instance
caches, things being written,
having to update, NDB actually
is doing all of this for you.
So if you're a Python user
and you're not using
NDB, check it out.
Hopefully, it's pretty easy to
translate one to the other.
And you'll get a lot of
really cool savings.
I don't know that much about
Java, but I hear Objectify has
some of the same stuff.
So you should check
that out, too.
And finally, here's just a
summary of what the difference
is between Datastore,
Memcache, and
instance caching are.
You can see here the latency.
Obviously, Datastore has
the biggest latency.
But also, you're storing
the most things there.
And it's written there, and
it's written near forever
unless you choose
to remove it.
In terms of the storage,
something to call out in
instance caching specifically,
is we do allow you to have
larger size instances
in App Engine.
The smallest size is the
default, but we do have bigger
sizes that costs more
money, that
have more memory available.
And one thing you could do with
that memory is store some
stuff in there to make your
application faster.
And the last thing I'm going
to cover in caching is
something that really will have
a huge benefit for pages
of your application that are
rarely updated with new
content, which is set cache
control headers.
It's such an easy thing to do.
But what it does is when
that request is sent to
intermediate servers and
browsers, it tells those
servers and browsers how long
to hold that page before
re-requesting it from
the server.
So that means that your app's
actually not going to have to
really do almost any work
for these requests.
You get those requests only for
bandwidth in App Engine.
And the thing you want to be
careful, of course, is that
you can't ever force these
pages to be re-requested
before the expiration time.
So please set it reasonably.
I mean, we've actually
seen apps that have
set it for 365 days.
And of course, they set
it, and they realize
they've made a mistake.
Well, once we've served
the requests,
it's out of our hands.
We can't force the servers.
We can't force the browser
to re-request anyway.
So make this a sane value,
but still use it.
And in fact, if you go in the
admin console, you can go to
the drop-down and do request
by type per second.
And what you'll see here is it
actually breaks down for this
application how many static
requests, but also, how many
requests are served
from edge caching.
And you can see here that those
requests I'm only really
paying bandwidth for.
My server's not doing any work,
or my instance isn't
doing any work.
So it's a great way to save
yourself some money and save
your computing power to do
something more interesting.
Now I'm going to hand it off
to Greg who's going to talk
about batch API requests.
GREG DARKE: So, what are
batch API requests?
Batch API requests allow you to
make operations on multiple
pieces of data in single RPC.
And doing this allows the App
Engine servers to actually fan
out your request to
multiple servers.
And it allows you to amortize
the cost of that RPC over
multiple pieces of data.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, I'm going to use the
example of Taskqueue here.
So say, for example,
I'd like to insert
50 tasks into Taskqueue.
Just simple code, it goes
through loops and adds them.
At the top here is a graph
from Appstats.
It was introduced by Guido van
Rossum in a Google I/O talk in
2010, so I suggest you have
a look at that for more
information.
But in this graph here, you can
actually see each of the
RPCs that's made by
the application.
I've actually trimmed off just
after about the first 10
because it goes down to 50.
As you can see, each request
here is taking about 10 to 15
milliseconds.
So overall, it's over 600
milliseconds to enter these
actual requests into
Taskqueue.
So if I change this code
slightly, so I still construct
all the tasks, add them to a
list, I'm using the batch API
interface, which is q.add.
You can see that all the tasks
are inserted, but it's only
taking 22 milliseconds.
So it makes the requests
much, much faster.
So we have many APIs that
actually support this--
Memcache, Datastore, Taskqueue,
Full Text Search.
They actually all support
being able to operate on
multiple entities for Datastore,
add multiple
documents to an index for
full-text search.
And Memcache, you can
either get or put
multiple entries there.
So some things you will have to
be careful of when you're
using the batch API with
Taskqueue, for example, is
that you can actually only
insert up to 32 megabytes
worth of requests there.
So using the batch APIs can be
slightly more complicated and
has some gotchas around the size
and the number of things
that you can add to them.
But overall, it's a considerable
win to both
latency and it makes your
application faster.
So I will just leave batch API
requests for a second.
I'll go onto using asynchronous
workflows.
So asynchronous workflows allows
you to start an RPC and
then continue doing work
in your application.
This allows you to do multiple
slow operations in parallel,
such as performing multiple URL
fetches as I've got here.
It also allows you to perform
CPU-intensive operations while
waiting for the IO
to complete.
This was alluded to by Marzia
earlier on with Datastore.
When you're doing a query in
Datastore using the .run
interface in Python and also in
Java, what actually happens
is we do an asynchronous call
to fetch the next set of
entities, so that we're
performing the IO to find the
next entries while you'll
still iterating over the
previous batch that
we returned.
So I'm just going to
go over a quick--
over an example of how to use
asynchronous RPCs to speed up
URL fetch in this example.
I'm going to give two
examples of this.
This is using the slightly older
method using callbacks.
And then I'll go over
the new one.
So the main thing that you need
to write here for using
any of the asynchronous APIs
is you'll actually need an
event loop that keeps track
of the RPCs and calls the
wait_any function, which will
automatically call the
callbacks when they're ready.
I have the do-fetch_call down
here, which inside it I have a
closure to construct the
actual callback.
And I'm passing it to
make_fetch_call, which is the
actual asynchronous version of
fetch in the URL fetch API.
In other APIs, the asynchronous
version is
generally named the same
as the normal version.
So if Datastore is get, the
asynchronous version is
get_asynch, and this
follows on.
URL fetch was our first
synchronous
API and is thus different.
So with this example here, I'm
passing the callback into the
create RPC function.
And so when the actual call is
being made and the request is
finished, this callback will
occur, k and we'll
be given the data.
So as you can see, this version
here actually doesn't
pass anything back from
that callback back
into the main function.
That's actually quite difficult
to do using the
callback model of programming
here.
So I will give you--
this is the new version
using NDB tasklets.
The main difference here is
that instead of having to
write your own event loop, NDB
has one written for you.
And, in fact, it actually makes
use of the new yield
statement as co-routines.
So all you have to do is wrap
the function with this
NDB.tasklet decorator, and then
you just yield any RPCs.
And this allows you to write
programs that look like they
flow straight down but actually
will be calling into
and out of the event loop.
So you can see this example
here does the same thing.
It calls make_fetch_call.
It just passes the
result back.
And we've actually got the
return statement here.
So in NDB, with tasklets, you
have to actually raise the
return exception, and that
result gets passed back into
the list down the bottom.
So if we have a look at the
actual before and after.
So before, with fetching four
RPCs-- sorry, four websites,
it actually takes nearly
4 seconds.
Doing it with an asynchronous
model, you can still do the
processing in between each
of these requests.
And in this case, it takes
just over 3 seconds.
So a fairly large saving.
But if this was in your main
handler, as Marzia alluded to
earlier, this still was probably
way too slow for you.
Some of the APIs that support
asynchronous--
Blobstore, Memcache, URLFetch,
and Datastore.
So what you may actually want
to do with requests, if you
wanted to gather data from an
external site and then be able
to serve it as a part of your
homepage request, what you may
want to do is actually cache
that data and actually cache
it in Datastore.
So Datastore, as we said
before, is about 50
milliseconds per request.
Whereas if you're looking at the
same thing for doing a URL
fetch to a slow external
resource, that can actually
take over 2 seconds.
So what you may actually want
to use offline processes for
is you can actually defer
updating those pages.
Because otherwise, when the
cache expires with just using
a naive solution, you would
actually still have to make
one person wait for that
2-second request to be able to
gather it again and
fill your cache.
Other things you can use
offline processes for--
Doing slow external, say,
billing processes.
You can also use it to make
workflow systems or perform
fan-in, which is described
in Brett
Slatkin's talk from 2010.
So I will actually go over
an example of how to use
Taskqueue and actually
do that URL fetching
example I gave before.
So I'm using NDB here.
The reason I'm using NDB is that
it gives the transparent
caching to Memcache and
the instance cache.
So if this was a fairly highly
used property and serving on
your home page, then this
actually may not have to even
go to Datastore at all.
It could already be fetched in
Memcache, or it could also
just be in the instance
cache already.
So going to the get URL
method, so I'll
skip truncate time.
It's just a helper method
used to ensure
that we don't fetch--
I don't create too many tasks
to actually fetch this.
So if we look at the get URL
method, we construct a key
name based on the URL.
We're using sha1, so that way,
we can actually ensure that
the name space of all these
keys is fairly evenly
distributed.
So the first that we do is we
just try and fetch it from
Datastore, if it's there.
If it's not there, we'll just
fetch it straight from the
external resource,
save it, and just
return it straight away.
So in the case of the first user
viewing this page, they
may actually have to pay the
2-second request delay here.
If you were implementing this
in your own code, you can
actually send a 302 back to the
user or send a placeholder
so that the page will render.
And then it can actually go back
to and try and re-request
the page so that the
user actually
sees something before.
So here, if we do find it in
Memcache or in Datastore, we
check if the data has expired.
If it has, we just defer
a task into Taskqueue.
And that will then
asynchronously go and fetch
the new version while we return
the current version
that's in the cache
back to the user.
And as you can see, with the
update cache method, it's just
a fairly simple fetch from the
external resource and then
blindly put it to Datastore.
So I will now pass along to
Troy who will talk about
performance settings.
TROY TRIMBLE: Great.
Thanks, Greg.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
TROY TRIMBLE: Test, test.
All right, there we go.
Let's just do it.
We'll do it live.
All right.
Hi, everybody.
I'm a senior software engineer
on App Engine.
And today I'm going to be
talking to you about
performance settings that you
can set for your app to
optimize for either low
cost or low latency.
So performance settings
are something we
introduced last year.
We haven't talked to them
publicly as far as I know,
like in a conference
to this setting.
So there's a few of them.
They're on the application
settings portion
of the admin console.
And you can see here that
there's the front-end instance
class that Marzia touched
on earlier.
There's idle instances, and
there's pending latency.
So the first thing I'd
like to talk to is
optimizing for low latency.
So why do you want to optimize
for low latency?
Well, it's pretty
straightforward.
You have a web UI or a mobile
frontend, and you want to have
a very, very snappy, good web
experience for your users.
So the first setting that you
can use is what we call
minimum idle instances.
And what this tells the App
Engine scheduler is that you
would prefer that it keep around
at least this number of
idle instances at all times
for your application.
And what these idle instances
are used for is to send
traffic to them when all of
your active or dynamic
instances are currently busy
serving other requests.
And so this is extremely useful
for things like bursty
or unpredictable traffic, such
that you don't have to suffer
the dreaded loading request
for a user-facing request.
And so what we will typically
tell both internal and
external partners
to do is to--
if they're going to have some
sort of event, like a Google
I/O event, or some sort of
press, or some new feature
that they think is going to just
drive a bunch of traffic
to their site, that they
temporarily increase this
number in order to sort of
buffer that bursty traffic.
And then, later on they can
turn it back down again in
order to save some more money.
The second setting that you can
set to optimize for low
latency is the max pending
latency setting.
And what this setting tells
the scheduler is that you
would prefer that no request to
your application wait for
longer than this amount of time
before being processed by
one of your instances.
And so again, this is something
to tell the
scheduler that if you really
want a sappy user experience
that it not wait for an
instance to turn up.
But it just automatically--
the scheduler should
automatically provision a
number of instances in order
to keep the average pending
latency below this threshold.
And so here's an example of the
instances console, which
is also in the admin console.
And you can see here that in
this case we've set three for
the min idle instances
setting.
And that is represented on the
right by the availability as
resident, and then the dynamic
ones below that are sort of
the active dynamic clones.
So you can see, as I mentioned
earlier, that the majority of
the requests to this application
have been handled
by the dynamic instances and
only a few have been handled
by the resident ones.
Here's an example of the
settings when actually setting
the min idle instances and
the max pending latency.
In this case, the admin console
is warning me because
I did not appropriately set the
warmup request setting in
my app.yaml or
appengine-web.xml.
And this is a requirement for
min idle instances to be used
appropriately by
the scheduler.
And that's because the scheduler
will spin up these
idle instances in the background
using what we call
warmup requests.
And you can read more
about that online.
I'd also like to touch on,
just very briefly, a new
feature that just came
out with 1.7.0.
And that is the page speed
service integration.
And I won't go into great depth
here, but it is a part
of the performance settings.
And what it will do is basically
will cache and do
content rewriting for a number
of your static resources in
order to, basically speed up
your service data content.
So next I'd like to talk to
optimizing for low cost.
And what I mean here, I mean
everybody wants to optimize
for low cost.
But in the performance settings
instance, what we're
really talking about here are
users who are hobbyists, or
people who have applications
that they're not really
monetizing their traffic.
They're running this thing for
free, and they want to just
try and keep their costs low
at the expense of having
potentially higher latency
user requests to their
application.
And the first setting
that we have
here is max idle instances.
And the idea is that you're
telling the App Engine
scheduler that you would prefer
that it not keep around
any more than this number of
idle instances to help serve
your application.
And this also factors into how
we calculate the front-end
instance hours charged
for your application.
Because if you told us I only
want three idle instances.
And for whatever reason, the
scheduler put up 10 idle
instances, well, then you
shouldn't be charged
for the extra 7.
The second setting here is
the min pending latency.
And what this says to the
scheduler is you would prefer
that the scheduler allow
requests to wait at least this
long before causing a loading
request and spinning up a new
instance to serve the request.
And what this does is basically
maximizes your
utilization of the instances
that you already have to try
and keep costs low.
So again, here's an example
of me setting these.
I've set the max idle instance
to 3 and the min pending
latency to 750 milliseconds.
And at this point, I'd like to
just take a brief moment
explain why I have specific
numbers here of 3 and 750
milliseconds.
These are not generally
applicable to all
applications.
They are just examples
that I've chosen.
The right number for your
application is completely
dependent upon your
application.
And we encourage you to try
and experiment with these
settings in order to find the
appropriate value for your
application.
Next, I'd like to talk about a
very serious anti-pattern that
we've seen far too many
times in the wild.
And this is basically using
both the low cost and low
latency settings together
simultaneously for your
application.
And the problem with this--
and you can see
what I've done here--
is that both min and max
idle instance is 15.
And the delta between the min
pending and max pending
latency is 50 milliseconds.
And the problem with these
settings is that it confuses
the App Engine scheduler
so much.
It just doesn't know how to
operate within such a thin
margin of these thresholds.
And what you see, as the App
Engine admin, is that your
application--
the scheduler will spin up
these instances for your
application, but they'll be
extremely short-lived.
They'll come into existence and
go out very, very quickly
while it tries to basically
satisfy these two thresholds.
And it basically makes a bunch
of churn in the system.
And it also will devalue things
like instance caching
because your instance cache
won't be around that long.
So our recommendation
is to not do this.
Our recommendation is to do
something like this where you
use just the low cost or just
the low latency settings, and
you set the other ones
to automatic.
So now I'd like to talk about
App Engine servers, which is
an ongoing project right now,
and how it'll affect the
performance settings that you
can set for your application
to make them more powerful and
more flexible going forward.
But first, I'd like to talk
about the motivation for why
we're doing this.
And the only way to do that is
by talking about what today's
App Engine hierarchy
looks like.
So as you can see here, we have
a top-level application.
Each application has some
set of servers--
or sorry, excuse
me, backends--
and some sort of versions.
And each of those has some
set of instances
associated with them.
And as a lot of you know if
you've been playing with the
performance settings before,
only the default version
receives the performance
settings that I
talked about just now.
And so what we've heard from
customers, from talking to
them and getting feedback on
the architecture as it is
today, is that one of the things
they really don't like
is that they only have a single
version that will auto
scale for them.
And only a single version
will receive
the performance setting.
So all the non-default versions,
they don't get these
performance settings.
So what we've done is we're
going to move to a world that
looks more like this,
basically.
We're going to introduce
a new level,
which is called a server.
And what a server is, it is a
conceptual grouping of versions.
The idea being though, that in
this new world the default
version of a server will now
be able to receive the
performance settings and have
those be active and also be
able to do autoscaling.
So you can have multiple servers
with multiple default
versions or a single default
version per server, but each
of those will be able to scale
independently of one another.
So, for example, you can have
a server with a default
version that is for your
patchwork, for your MapReduce.
And those performance settings
can try to utilize the
instances as much as possible
because all you're trying to
do is get throughput.
You don't need low latency,
you just need throughput.
Similarly, you continue to have
your web UI frontend that
has extremely low latency and
high min idle instances in
order to handle bursty traffic
and give a really snappy user
experience.
And so to give an example of
what these might look like in
the future, like how we're
going to do performance
settings in the future, is that
we're going to actually
take them from the admin console
and put them into your
app.yaml or your App
Engine web.xml.
And so when you upload your
code, you will also upload the
performance settings
that you feel
appropriate for that code.
And to give an example of that,
here is, for example, my
mobile frontend server.
So you can see here this is in
app.yaml, but there will be
the equivalent in the
App Engine web.xml.
And you can see here, though,
that there's a new field
called server.
This is my mobile frontend.
We're going to have
also a new section
called server settings.
And so you can see here it's
exactly the same settings that
we had in the admin console.
In this case, I've set to an F2
and 25 min idle instances
and the max pending
latency of 250.
The automatics are there just
for completeness, but are
actually unnecessary.
Those are the default values.
And so this is an example of
what today is traditionally
called a backend.
This is what it will look
like in the future.
We're actually going to move
the settings from what is
today in backends.yaml or
backends.xml and we're going
to put them into the actual
app.yaml or App Engine web.xml
going forward.
And so, in this case, you see
this is my geo backend server.
It has 10 instances.
Static, just 10 instances,
no autoscaling.
And it has an instance class of
B8 because I need a bunch
of memory to do a bunch
of great geo caching.
And so just to recap, Marzia
covered a lot of great
Datastore modeling patterns and
anti-patterns, along with
a number of caching
techniques.
Greg talked about the batch
APIs, some of the synchronous
APIs that we have and some
offline processing techniques.
And I covered today's
performance settings and what
they're going to look
like in the future.
And so with that, we'd like to
thank all of you for coming.
It's been a pleasure to
talk to you today.
And we would like to open up
the floor for questions.
I'd like to say very briefly
though, if you have a question
that pertains specifically to
your app that you don't think
would apply to other people in
the room, that you come find
us afterwards given that this
is kind of a forum where we
want to answer general questions
as much as possible.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You were talking about
just selecting certain
fields and that it's
much cheaper.
I'm wondering why--
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Project--
hello?
It's on?
Oh.
Projection queries?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Could it be also cheaper
than a get or
is it just for querying?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: They're both
small Datastore ops, so
they're basically equivalent.
But obviously, if you
are going to--
I mean, you should always
use gets first.
But if you have to do a query,
then using a projection query
is going to save you money.
I mean, if your entity
is sufficiently
small, it's the best.
Because sometimes projection
queries can take slightly
longer if the entity
is too large.
But for only a few fields,
it's a small op
versus a read op.
AUDIENCE: And if you do query
and you do it keys only, and
then do the gets separately and
interleaf with Memcache,
would your recommendation be
just to do a projection query
or do a key only query and then
try to find the entities
in the Memcache?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: So in that
case, if you're doing a keys
only query and then a get, it's
two small ops versus the
one small op for the
projection query.
So I believe you'd still be
better off, in that case, to
do projection queries.
Oh, and also, we have chocolate,
like the last
session for people who
ask questions.
So if you want afterwards, you
can come up and get some.
AUDIENCE: Just curious if you
have some debugging tips for
slow queries?
I often find, especially if
I'm fetching a lot of
information, it seems to be
going really slow, and it's
kind of hard to debug because
it's somewhat asynchronous so
you don't really see the cost
until later when you're using
the information.
And there's not a lot
of visibility into--
under the hood, it seems like
when you're making queries
that are within a bunch of
keys, there's lots of
situations where it's ultimately
making multiple
individual fetches and not doing
the sort of batch fetch
you might expect a real
SQL database to do.
So just, in general, how
do I go and look and
see, why is this slow?
Is it really hitting an index?
What is it that's
taking so long?
Is it the amount of
data that's being
transferred, et cetera.
Because it feels a little
opaque to me sometimes.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: I think queries
always hit indexes.
But--
PETE WHITE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Right.
But I think in this
case when--
so I'm not a super Datastore
expert, but like zigzag
queries where you're joining
multiple things.
I mean, I'm probably not the
right person to answer this in
detail, maybe Greg.
GREG DARKE: I'll just say if you
want to come and chat with
us afterwards, we'd probably be
able to help you with that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But I just wonder, are there
basic pages on the stats or
something that show you,
kind of here are the
queries you're making.
Here are the slow queries, or
here's how long they're taking
in general, or here's how much
data you're transferring, or
how many different RPCs
you're actually
making on the backend?
TROY TRIMBLE: The Appstat stuff
that we were showing
those, where like most of the
clips in here with sort of the
timelines and stuff like that,
which most of them were in
Greg's talk, that's an extremely
valuable debugging
tool that you can do on a
single request basis.
And it does have--
at least for Python, it has a
full stack dump where it will
drop you to the exact line
of code that executed it.
So you really can drill down and
say, like, oh, this query
took a really long time.
It executed out of order
with this other one.
And so this is the one I
need to really find.
And it will tell you what the
line of code that is.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: But
I also think--
I mean, so there used to be
more queries that required
composite indexes that then
they made not required.
But you can still
re-add composite
indexes for some queries.
Those will write more indexes,
but they might be faster.
But again, it's like there's a
lot of dependencies there that
I'm probably not the best
expert to tell you.
But that is one option also
when it used to require a
composite index and now
no longer does.
Adding back the composite index
might speed up the query
in that case.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
GREG DARKE: Up the back?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
had a question.
I'm wondering if you had any
plans of reducing the pricing
maybe or maybe offering tier
pricing for things like games
where it's harder to monetize
at the rate that the current
pricing is.
TROY TRIMBLE: I mean, we have
no plans on reducing pricing
right now as far as I know.
We're always evaluating.
We know that we just came out
with new pricing for Compute
Engine and stuff like
that that is tiered.
So that seems to be the way that
things are going, but we
have nothing to announce
today, unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
I've noticed whenever I
configure a resident instance
with the min idle instance, my
app, at like 2:00 in the
morning when no one's hitting it
and I have an idle instance
that I'm paying for, if I hit up
my app, it prefers to just
spin up a dynamic instance
instead of kind of using what
I'm paying for.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: So that min
idle instances are really more
geared toward handling
bursty traffic.
So we always prefer
dynamic instances.
But we keep the idle instances
around in case we haven't
predicted correctly whether or
not there's enough dynamic
instances around to serve it.
So that's really the purpose.
What I always kind of use in
an example is, if you're
launching a website and you
might have a really steep,
really sharp jump.
And it's hard for us to predict
exactly how that's
going to go.
So then you might want to spin
up a lot of idle instances
because those instances
can serve a request
kind of in a pinch.
But when you have traffic that's
more steady state or
easy kind of flowing traffic,
the idle instances aren't as
useful because we're usually
really good at predicting when
to do a dynamic instance.
AUDIENCE: So it's for burst,
not start-up time?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: I mean,
it's for both.
But you should think of it as
something that can serve a
request while the dynamic
request is spinning up.
AUDIENCE: Bingo.
OK, cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you for App Engine.
And you said not to use limit
and offset, obviously because
that's very inefficient,
right?
TROY TRIMBLE: It's just really
offset in that case.
AUDIENCE: Oh, offset.
That's right.
TROY TRIMBLE: Limit's fine,
just no offset.
AUDIENCE: I meant that, yeah.
But what about if you want to
page back and page forward?
Cursor, you use cursor, right?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: There's a start
and end cursor, both.
I just use the start cursor.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Start cursor.
But let's say you have a pay and
you want to go backward.
Can you go backwards
and forward?
The cursor only goes
forward, right?
TROY TRIMBLE: No, you can set
an end cursor on a query.
That's what she's saying.
So by default, it's like there's
start_cursor and
end_cursor.
So you can say--
I believe it's at the end, like,
basically of your query,
you should have that cursor
should be the
end of it, I believe.
I know I'm not explaining
that very well.
AUDIENCE: There's got to
be a better way of--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
But you can't always--
I can't always do that.
I'll ask after.
AUDIENCE: Is server
configuration enabled now or
next version?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: So the server
configuration is just what
we're working on implementing
now.
And one of the main reasons to
bring it up is because--
I mean, I think we really are
looking for feedback on how
that might be the most useful
for you and give you an idea
of what we're thinking
about in the future.
We don't have a target
release date, per se.
TROY TRIMBLE: Yeah, we're
working on this
actively right now.
If you'd like to talk more about
it, I encourage you to
come find me after we're done
here, and I'd love to hear
feedback that you have
on it or thoughts.
Definitely.
That goes for everybody.
AUDIENCE: Is there any way to
visualize pending latency?
The one that you don't see in
the request and to me it seems
it's nowhere reported.
Also on the dashboard, right?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: It's
in the logs.
And what I would actually plug
for here is actually we don't
have this--
we actually haven't written
this, but it's probably really
useful, is we have a Logs Reader
API, which actually
allows you to either MapReduce
or read through your logs.
And you could do something like
read the pending latency.
Read all your requests, the
information about your
requests, dump it into something
like BigQuery, or
even write a custom kind
of visualization for
those kinds of logs.
I mean, the raw tools for the
stuff is here, but it's kind
of very nascent in terms of
making these really easy to
use for you.
But it's possible.
And I think it's really exciting
to be able to read
your logs, dump them into
BigQuery, do queries.
And I think it's something
we want to enable
better in the future.
But obviously, you guys
could do it now.
And there's always
open sourcing it.
I mean, not to plug it, but
this is something I really
want to use and haven't
had time to write.
If you wanted to write
it, you could.
And it would be really useful.
But for your own application
and for other people's
applications.
TROY TRIMBLE: Yeah, well, it's
not well visualized in graphs
or anything like that, like
on the dashboard.
Like she said, it is not only in
the Logs API, the data you
get back from there, but it is
in the Logs Reader in the
admin console.
It's right in the first line
of every request, tells you
like a pending--
it's like pending_ms.
And it tells you.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: If it sat in
the pending queue, it's
pending_latency in the logs.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about the
implementation of embedded
entities and how the performance
characteristics
would compare to other kind of
straightforward options that
you have right now, like
JSONifying an entity, or
pickling it.
GREG DARKE: So the embedded
entities are actually just
another Datastore model that's
just been serialized and then
stored in a blob field.
Sorry.
For local structured property,
they're stored in a blob field
in the object.
And you can actually compress
that if you want.
For structured properly,
we take the name of the
properties, and we mutate them
so that we can actually still
allow you to do queries
over that.
So as for the performance, the
serialization time is the same
as it would take to serialize
the two entities.
The right performance for local
structured property is
just the amount of time required
to put that data.
With local structured
properties, because there's no
extra indexes, you don't have
to pay the time waiting for
those indexes to be written
to propagate.
But other than that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
local entities, local
structured entities, which you
said is linearized data.
So what happens when
you write it back?
Does it again redistribute
it and write it?
Or do you write it
in one place?
Let's say, for example, you have
blog post and you have
profile information.
Profile information being
a local entity into--
MARZIA NICCOLAI: So it
only writes it in the
place you write it.
I didn't really cover how you
might use this, like fully to
denormalize.
It's just to point out how you
can store a structure.
When you put it in the one
entity, it just writes that
one entity.
It doesn't update
it everywhere.
You still have to do
that yourself.
But it's really nice because it
gives you a nice, logical
way of understanding and
structuring this to facilitate
denormalization, which obviously
helps with queries.
So I didn't cover
that part of it.
AUDIENCE: The max limit of
writing 100 or 1,000 entities
per transaction still applies
when you write it in--
GREG DARKE: So with local
structured property, it
actually only counts
as a single
entity that you're writing.
But you still have to
adhere to the one
megabyte per entity limit.
So you can actually have as
many values in that local
structured property as you want,
as long as they will fit
within the one megabyte size
limit of the entity that
contains that local structured
property.
AUDIENCE: So if I have a
thousand blog posts and if I
write one profile which is
1 MB, it's still fine?
So you don't have to worry
about writing it as 1,000
megabytes, right?
Am I making sense here?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: I'm not sure
that we understand exactly.
So the structured property is
stored within the one entity.
AUDIENCE: Think of it like
a blog post and a profile
information.
A profile information lives
inside the blog post because
you want to denormalize
it just in
case you want to query.
So if you have to write a
change to the profile
information--
MARZIA NICCOLAI: You'd have
to write it everywhere.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question
about queries.
Let's suppose I have an
entity with 10 fields.
I'm assuming if I query all 10
fields, it's a full-entity
read, right?
What determines the threshold,
if it's a small read or--
MARZIA NICCOLAI: If you use
a projection query and you
actually call out all 10
fields, it's still
just the small op.
The thing that might happen
there is the index scans might
take a little bit longer.
So it might not be faster,
but it will be cheaper.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Wait, 7?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARZIA NICCOLAI: No, no.
It's one small op.
We had Alfred.
AUDIENCE: There was an issue
where, I forget what version,
but the static files in the log
were no longer showing the
refer in the access log.
Is Page Speed going to fix
that, or is that going to
still have that issue?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG DARKE: Do you want
to answer it?
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Page Speed,
I think, is orthogonal.
TROY TRIMBLE: Meet Pete
White, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
PETE WHITE: For that specific
issue, I know the thing there
was that we do not get every
piece of information that we
have from normal requests
for edge cache requests.
So if you have billing enabled,
you're serving a
static resource, and it's coming
out of our edge cache.
We don't necessarily have the
response size, or the refer,
or I think like the user
agent field, so
some of that's missing.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: So Page Speed
is actually our integration
with the other Google
service Page Speed.
So that is totally kind of
unrelated to this issue.
What that does is that uses that
service to compress like
CSS files and sometimes
JavaScript files and serve
them from the page
speed cache.
So it's really quick.
So these two issues
are not related.
AUDIENCE: Just a small comment
on my question before.
With graphing pending latency,
I just checked.
Actually, the latest ProdEagle
library allows you to graph
out the pending latency.
Just as FYI for everybody
who was wondering.
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Cool.
GREG DARKE: Great.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GREG DARKE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: If you're already
minifying and combining your
JS and CSS files, does Page
Speed give you any advantage?
TROY TRIMBLE: I'd refer to the
documentation on this one.
I know that basically they have
a number of options that
you can choose depending
on what you want to do.
For example, there's
CSS inlining.
And I don't know if they
do spriting or
anything like that.
But, I mean, basically each
individual option does some
optimization that is separate
from the others.
So it really depends on what
you're looking for.
AUDIENCE: Would it be an
advantage putting it in the
Page Speed cache?
TROY TRIMBLE: Yeah.
I mean, caching is
always good.
So yeah, I mean, it would be an
advantage to put it in the
Page Speed cache.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'll experiment with that.
Thank you.
PETE WHITE: I think there will
be better documentation
forthcoming, but the Page Speed
service is very, very
similar to the open source
page speed--
Mod Page Speed Apache plug-in.
So the sorts of things there
are exactly what we're
exposing, just built
into your app.
AUDIENCE: I'm already using the
Google Closure Tools that
does a pretty good
job already.
That would be nice.
GREG DARKE: Thank
you very much.
If anyone else wants to--
MARZIA NICCOLAI: Yeah, if you
asked a question, remember to
come get your chocolate bars.
And if you want to
come talk to us
individually, we'll be here.
[APPLAUSE]